has been pretty much obliterated it was
the village closest to the russian
leader's biggest military defeat in this
war so far
and it was absolutely hammered in the
weeks before
virtually every building is torn apart
and there are the remnants of cluster
bombs left exposed in the farmland
around
we're taken through unmarked forest
routes the ukrainian soldiers where with
want to avoid detection by the russian
front lines just across the river and
thirsty for revenge
very few have been allowed to see for
themselves what happened on the ground
here
but the graveyard of russian combat
vehicles will go down in the ukrainian
military history books at least as one
of the federation's most humiliating
defeats
today
ukrainian military footage shows broken
pontoon bridges which the russians had
built to cross the dinettes river in
order to surround severe donetsk the
last big ukrainian holdout in luhansk
part of the donbass
the footage shows russian vehicles some
already in the river being attacked on
all sides
russian soldiers are seen jumping from
the top of their armored vehicle into
the water to escape
certainly the wreckage we saw indicated
there'd been significant losses the
ukrainians say hundreds of russians were
killed although that's difficult to
verify as the bodies had been cleared
before we got here
our soldier guides were hugely curious
about the enemies they've slain here
going through their supplies and
collecting them as memorabilia
this significant win has massively
boosted their morale
here
the ferocity of the firepower was
intense and the ukrainians say they
wiped out a whole battalion
but perhaps more long-lasting damage is
what it's done
to the top of the russian federation
because it's led to criticism that they
haven't seen ever before and that
criticism is directly linked to vladimir
putin himself
still desperate to take several donetsk
that's forced changes on the eastern
front the citizens of solidar a few
kilometers south are the fresh focus of
russian firepower there's now a huge
crater on the main street
the sound is the ukrainians responding
with volleys of grad rockets
with few shots left open and supplies
running out they cannot believe what's
happening to their farming community
this used to be the theater but also
stored some aid and even explosions
provide opportunities
[Applause]
here see russia as the aggressor but
alex is unusual and has big doubts about
exactly who's doing the bombing
this is ukrainians
bombs here
not not russian you think ukrainians
bombed this
you would prefer the war to end
and you think russia taking this
territory will lead to the end of the
war yes so you think ukraine should give
it to russia
maybe
but
i see donetsk now
i think
that's
this is better
to to go to russia for it to go to
russia no yes
the ukrainian president has warned that
donetsk and luhansk which make up the
donbass region are being turned into
hell and this is what it looks like the
final stages of this war are likely to
be the bloodiest he's predicted and an
awful lot of blood has already been
spilled here
alex crawford sky news in the donbass